It’s hard to figure out just what elevates
an actor’s performance into greatness.
Sometimes it’s commitment.
Other times it’s technical skill, the sheer
ability of a performer to portray the subtleties
and nuances of a challenging character.
Often the right role simply fits an actor
like a glove.
And occasionally, if everything plays out
just right, all these things can happen at
once, making for some of the greatest moments
in movie history.
These are a few of those moments.
Becoming less than human
There's a tremendous degree of difficulty
in performing the role of a human stripped
of their humanity, someone whose soul has
been ravaged to the point of no return.
And no actor has managed it quite like Choi
Min-sik in Park Chan-wook’s brutal masterpiece
Oldboy.
Choi stars as Oh Dae-su, a man out for revenge
after being imprisoned in a hotel room under
mysterious circumstances by unknown forces.
There’s little recognizable humanity in
Dae-su when he first emerges from his makeshift
prison, and what remains has been stripped
away by the film's climax.
Choi scrapes down into the absolute depths
of the human soul and offers a turn which
audiences will likely never forget, no matter
how much they’d like to.
Digging deep
Gavin O'Connor's 2011 drama Warrior is one
of the unsung triumphs of the decade.
What could have been a glorified Lifetime
cable drama instead turned out as a heart-wrenching
story about fathers, sons, and brothers.
Joel Edgerton and Nick Nolte delivered their
own remarkable performances, but it was Tom
Hardy who really made the movie what it is.
Hardy's character Tommy is a raw, exposed
nerve of a human being, ravaged by trauma,
guilt, and hate.
Hardy masks the character's confusion, sadness,
and fear with a shield of brashness that deflects
every friendly hand that comes his way.
“Are we done, Brendan?
Are we finished?”
It's a testament to Hardy's own talents that
his character never becomes outright unlikable,
despite the script giving us every reason
to hate him.
The sum of their parts
Even the most stellar ensemble casts are outshone
by one or two standout characters.
Pulp Fiction has Vincent and Jules.
The Usual Suspects is very much Verbal's story.
But the best ensemble movies are defined by
a cast of characters who all excel together.
It’s rare, but it happens, and The Breakfast
Club is the best example of this kind of movie.
It's impossible to pinpoint a single performance
among the main cast as the best, not only
because they're all just so good, but because
removing one piece of the ensemble would bring
everything tumbling down.
“Now it’s eight.
You stay out of it.”
“Excuse me, sir, it’s seven.”
“Shut up, Pee Wee.”
Some of the finest teen stars of the 1980s
were brought together to form the eponymous
Breakfast Club, including Molly Ringwald,
Anthony Michael Hall, Emilio Estevez, Judd
Nelson, and Ally Sheedy.
Each cast member works in perfect tandem with
the other four, and every character receives
equal focus.
There's no lead or standout actor, and the
result is a collective performance that’s
nothing less than magical.
Nearing the breaking point
In Do the Right Thing, Spike Lee's Mookie
is a man adrift.
Caught in his day-to-day life between working
for a family of racist Italian-Americans and
his friendships with other aggrieved African-Americans,
Mookie is a character driven by a powerful
and almost unresolvable frustration.
Lee takes the character on a journey from
selfish passivity to insatiable fury, channeling
the character's anger and slowly building
towards an inevitable breaking point.
“Hey!”
His performance was one of the best of the
decade, and is as powerful today as when the
movie was first released.